you
it's a crazy house three two tournaments
45 minutes of crazy house and I am
paired up in this round one let's say
against John Madden
okay I feel like I could breathe some
this is a slower time control which is
nice we're gonna play Bishop e7 this is
quite an adjustment from regular chess
must I must say so Bishop e7 designed
against chop and then check
let's get castled that way my King
doesn't have to recapture I thought that
doesn't matter White's still going
straight in for an attack on f7 alrighty
hmm what to do here thinking about
Knight d4 yeah whatever
what are you Ethan you're not gonna
calculate it all let's see if they go in
for the sacrifice here and then drop a
pawn or whatever it's always a
possibility they could just go straight
in for that oh really
I guess preparing to meet Knight takes
Knight with a pawn drop here interesting
hmm it's kind of scary must be said it's
kind of scary hmm well I'm gonna take
with my king let's see what you got on
Drop here hmm
I want to just ignore and play a night
drop on h4 have him bring the pain let
his presence be felt right away I think
I like that idea
hmm yeah let's get them in there strike
a g2
Wow crazytown game-pod takes think I'll
immediately recapture no no no no no no
no no I'm not going to do that I'm gonna
take this guy first King f1 and then
I'll recapture let's do it
looking f1 I guess
all right now I could consider capturing
here or just playing a pawn in this
Square and then they give a knight check
here hmm
I'm gonna just recapture a queen check
here I could do a pawn drop so I could
secure my King here from it's really the
direct checks pieces right next to the
king that are giving check if you can't
block with something over here in your
pocket so on King takes Knight I'm
definitely going to drop here and then
if King here definitely a pawn drop here
with the fork but you know I think their
King is a little bit more vulnerable
they have a knight
let's see what this Queens gonna be up
to it was my move here I might want to
do this if he moves I have that a lot of
different possibilities okay interesting
mm-hmm well I don't think that that's
correct
cuz I could take and then after their
Queen recaptures I could play Knight
here or night here drop
umm-hmm might one just play night h4
they'd have to give a check otherwise I
drop with check I'm gonna do this for
starters I'll link these nights I have
to give a queen check queen h5 I'm
pretty sure and I'm gonna block with the
pawn cuz King here then if they get a
pawn at some point or a bishop they drop
it into h7 so I just need to cut out the
Queen's influence on these three squares
right away if they play queen h5 well
their queen right now I have ideas ooh
I was gonna say I have ideas to give a
check and then drop here so I have a
queen so I'm gonna actually lure their
king out now and I could do that by
playing first this check queen drop on
g2 if they don't take and I'm getting
they're getting their rook they have
three nights they're checking squares
for the nights
well it's only this one but I have it
covered so now I'm gonna do this
definitely let's check and I have
another piece I could be taking they
could drop there though huh hmm oh I
have a queen drop here you goof what
should I do that right away I'm gonna
take some material first the Queen
Bishop and pawn 19 seconds they have
three Knights what they can't do
anything with it all right
well how about we just take some more
stuff oh they're gonna give a night
check there can always take twice
then I could drop a night okay let's pin
their night now yep okay this is gonna
be enough now I could drop a queen I
could take some stuff this is it's has
to be winning let's start with this okay
4.5 seconds upon drop on g4 here we go
you got a rook now and a queen
where's the mate that's not it um I
could have done better this is not good
but how I'm doing this I should have had
me yikes
by now no we got it I'm sure there are a
million different ways I could have
finished that sooner but I'll take the W
at the end of the day Wow
a nine minute game all right
top has four and fire hmm okay I'm
noticing something that's a little bit
different there's a trend that pieces
are a little bit transparent here
normally it was just nothing seen at all
I must admit it's my minimal experience
with this variant I see that like I have
an easier time I feel at least playing
the d4 based structures he four moves
seemed much more critical now these
these games tend to be a bit more
interesting in lengthier
this is quite common to see h3 there
which stops a a possible pawn drop of my
own to h3 no idea what white is lining
up with their Knight b5 not really too
concerned about captured two either
these two okay well I could kick that
night away this is a move I would play
in regular chess I think it's still good
though hmm no you know what I'm going to
do actually
anticipating a pond drop on h6 I'm gonna
play h6 because when things heat up a
pond drop on this square and then this
guy gets broken down okay
threatening to take and then take here
so let's drop back I think that this is
a nice home for my king sometimes I've
seen you know a prophylactic move in
crazy house where you just move your
king to the corner don't really know if
I want to do that right now he seems to
be pretty good here let's let's kick
that night away and follow up with the
knight c6 most of my attention and crazy
house is in this quadrant right next to
their King oh they have that move ah
that's kind of stings well can you do
they're dropping here now I would really
like to have my King here hmm all right
they're gonna soon have a bishop should
I just take that pawn yeah that's right
I'm gonna do that and then repair my
structure as soon as possible it's true
they could take either of these but no
Knight takes rook I'm going to take with
the bishop and I guess I go with that so
they have two bishops my week on any one
color complex not really so they have
two bishops versus two knights I think
this is still fine I have those
structure a cozy home for my king and I
would prefer to Knights over to bishops
Bishop on h4 can hurt okay so it's
getting interesting in the center what
could my knight - that would be
dangerous let's start with the capture
and then we're gonna drop a knight right
in the center we're threatening Pawnee
to drop
controlling some squares it's really
these two I'm keying in on they could
drop a pond here to stop a pond drop of
my own on e2 now this is a really good
configuration for light oh they missed
this actually then it's really close to
me this is the only square with the King
if I did a knight drop here but I'm
pretty sure of Han drop here's excellent
so let's be careful oh well I don't need
to do it right now and you could do it
after the game right
I should have the promotion to not
always Queen on let's take the rook I
have another night I have a rook but I
feel like I still need some more more
pieces involved I think this is a good
start I'm threatening to go here and
then key in on this f3 square hmm okay I
think I want to start with the night
here really on these squares now I have
three square Queen us to be extra
careful
there's also Forks on c2
how'd they defend this square oh they're
just giving up the Queen for two nights
okay hmm well I'm gonna start with the
check here it's quite limited with what
they can do otherwise I'm winning a
piece two pawns two nights I have a
night um I think I'm just gonna start
with grabbing some material
well I do pawn drop here take my rook
get a clean 23 seconds that mo I'm gonna
go here I don't want to take I don't
want to move my knight because they'll
do a pawn drop here and disrupt my king
position 13 seconds for Queen um I'm
gonna get my Queen involved right now I
want to take on h3 Wow
or I could take here actually that was
the other thing I have another pawn
don't have much time mmm the knight
moves I could take the vish are if they
have a knight and up on they did a night
job let's just duck okay they're out of
pieces no let's move him they have a
crazy night
scary it is scary I have something I
could drop here maybe Bishop on that
square I want to clean right here or
rook I'm going to do a knight drop here
hmm
area near my king very scary gotta take
that
let's take here I need to start giving
checks oh this is a good move because I
get this night with cheque
that move and then a bishop on g14 check
we're getting there let's just lure the
King out I checked there check there
what's that mate
those d4 Gabe's man Wow
all right this I played two games so far
27 minutes remain
Ferraris playing oh he is a very good
crazy house trading
good crazy house player we've played um
well I think a few crazy house games I
don't remember the rating being this
high so he's clearly been learning he
has 14 eight eight top three I have four
and fire this next one's an important
one to get up there with these guys
Hebrews irked the first two and this is
my first game with white all right let's
go we're right out here in pinpoints f7
and develop taken of two or not all
right I like this idea of a knight
jumping into d5 so I'm an issue for that
let's go for it right now
one night here but a bishop on this
square is pretty good I think a bishop
move to this square it's important I
play here to kind of kill this night
they could [ __ ] they could a pileup on
the night the night h4 and that could be
kind of tricky there I might have to
play Knight II one they're not going for
that so they gave me an opportunity to
pin the night hmm I wonder however on
this move I think a move is Knight takes
Bishop so I'm gonna take this out and
then play Bishop g5 I like this for two
reasons a it pins the knight and B it
stops one of their drops on h4 if I have
a pawn I would think about dropping it
there so asking a question about if I
think I want to maintain that pin and I
may want to do this given given a chance
I think they should drop something here
they don't have a knight
I think I'm Knight here would be
fantastic I guess we'll just go to
Bishop b2 stuff that's happening on the
Queen side doesn't concern me as much as
the King side so I have two knights I'm
thinking about dropping one of them may
be right on f5 mmm couple ideas
Bishop drop here it's always a little
bit scary moving too many pawns from
your second ring because this allows
future black pawns to be dropped here
then be just a single step away from
queening so yeah they're going straight
in for that huh I feel like I should
have something just take the bishop yeah
again this is action on the Queen side
so it doesn't concern me so much maybe
maybe dropping things like a bishop here
multi-purpose stuff defends my King
strikes here okay that's a very slow
move two poems and a bishop is what they
have a knight drop here threatens a
bishop here I could take their night
yeah I could take their night
oh you know what I'm gonna do bishop
drop here attack the rook and prepare to
maybe sacrifice on this square maybe
yeah multi-purpose move here
Bishop d2 drop
well Ferrari is
14:14 12:10 are now at the top and
they're ready uh-huh yeah let's let's
look to disrupt their king position now
I'm gonna start throwing some strikes at
them
my D is a follow up on drop on g5 let's
see what does let's go here two bishops
and two pawns I have two knights
all right now if they try
to drop upon here I could do this
starting to okay now starting to control
some squares all right and I think I
might go as far as taking here let's see
or yeah I'm gonna take here I like this
idea I've said it before where if you
could invest one of your minor pieces if
you give up if you're able to give up
one of your minor pieces for an enemy
pawn and lure the enemy King forward
one-ranked I think you're you're making
some headway so now I could do a pawn
drop on one of these two I like this one
actually because now if I have another
pawn there's a drop here actually I
miscalculated some I thought I would be
able to do it back to back drop um all
right this this feels right I'm okay
with giving up my queen I'm looking at
night drops here if the bishop takes
pawn takes with check upon drop here I
have a lot of good ideas and this this
should be working somehow take this guy
if I need to I think I'm gonna go
straight in for the fork and let me
actually I might need a knight in this
game never okay yeah I'm seeing a
position where I might want to take the
rook and get a knight whit's check I
should have changed that after that last
game forgot they're down to 15 seconds
okay now I could take their queen though
um not going to do that I'm gonna take
here all I need is a queen and then I
could do this or even a rook is I'm
gonna go with the Queen though Queen
drop here for me
got a knight drop here even so I think I
could do this because I have their queen
hmm I'm getting their queen and now I'm
getting a knight drop right here and I
get a queen drop next so this should be
winning hmm let's start with this they
have a queen take either night you got
to keep giving checks I feel let's see
which one they take bold very bold
I should have mate though start with
this Queen here I'm king here and this
should be leading to mate I have so much
yeah this is made actually okay got
three games in don't get too many no top
guy Ferrari he only has five nineteen
for re 12 12 10 all right let's see if I
get another white game in this win would
put me up there in second third place
area Ferrari is playing right now let's
take a quick peek at his game he's got a
queen in pawn he's in berserk mode his
king is running for his life
mmm it's gonna be tough to control he
has four pawns in a bishop feels like
black would have something here
I guess I'm not paired up yet let me
just double-check you know if I guess
it'll go away he's in check he's at 30
seconds for pawns for black isn't this
me
yeah you got made it alright I might be
getting paired up with Ferrari he took a
a loss his first loss here he doesn't
have fire when I could get paired up
with either these two I think I'll get
one of them let's see
hoping for the white pieces let's see
43 players in this from now you're still
in there I didn't withdraw no I'm
neither player alright the French honey
d5 I like a 5 this this this isn't right
this can't be right too weak enough 6
that early
playing e5 soon in dropping pieces there
I guess I don't know let's get this
night out yet to weaken this square so
early don't think it could be the right
idea
mmm go here and definitely bypassing
that so already a pawn drop on this
square is going to get some serious
stuff or even this
a pawn drop on h6 is quite annoying I
imagine even this is an idea with the
pawn drop here I'm looking at these
furthest advanced pawns and looking at
drops on these squares
this is also a position I don't think I
need to rush I could just get my King
castled maybe even make a prep move just
as we would you know make a flight
square in regular chess I think this is
a really good all-purpose move for crazy
house to prevent pawn drops on h3 you
play each through yourself it does
weaken g3 and they're right but I don't
think this is a moment where I really
should focus so much on defensive stuff
for my King I think I could be quite
direct against their King position
against their weak squares an f6 I take
the pawn and then I could soon replace
it with another pawn on e5 you should
probably do that ya know definitely have
an airy King that move all right I think
I'm just going to take and now look for
a bishop or pawn drop to control some
stuff maybe even a bishop and drop on g7
or a pawn drop on g7 alright a bishop
drop here with force and Knight takes or
I could just do a pawn drop I think I
like a pawn drop let's see I could take
upon if I need it okay
bishop drop here or maybe something like
this I might want to just go in here
yeah I think I'm gonna continue with
this stuff they have to give up some
material I know they're winning up on
like this but I feel like I just want to
continue with the attack and continually
generate threats so I think that this is
right and it take giving up some
material but I'm looking at this move
hitting the Queen again and now a knight
on f6 check next they have a lot of fuel
let's see where their Queen goes could I
could hunt down a knight if I really
need one there should be five of course
I would like to already just be in a
position to take the knight out in one
swing one twenty little time edge here I
think I'm gonna go straight in for that
check just to get him on board maybe
take that pawn King here I have this so
where's that King headed hmm well I'm
gonna take this pawn and think about a
drop here yeah there King is definitely
can't feel too good I think they could
already take some action against my king
with pawn drop on h3 I think that's an
excellent start but I'll probably ignore
it and drop a pawn right here and
they're not going with that so let's go
here for starters let's see see where
the Queen goes maybe
pressure on them in the clock Queen
there I feel like I want to take care I
might be investing too much material my
night is under fire and I'm gonna I'm
gonna go with that I'm running with very
little fuel I realize but I am
controlling squares around their king
and maybe what next okay if I get there
night and night drop here would be
deadly so I'm gonna do this looking to
take the night and then a night drop on
this square wits check picking him up
these have to be a pretty serious force
as far as what they have they have some
checks their nights they're not
threatening anything with that move I'm
gonna take their night with check easy
to calculate much easier to calculate
when you are doing stuff with check
maybe they take with the king I don't
know I might want to do this oh really
that can't work and I could take this
pawn and then can also drop a knight if
we exchange Queen's Queen drops to one
of these two will be deadly so certainly
take here I'm on the rook another pawn
drop
I don't need very much material I think
I could just take some more stuff
yeah I don't see that it's threatening
anything on each - got that covered
under ten seconds okay that's definitely
not working flavor on c7 now I'm gonna
drop a knight though because I want
things to hit with check I want to take
the rook weights check I want to drop a
rook wits check and that's check in the
last piece that I have is just enough
gas for me back to tournament 22 is in
first Ferraris in first 2014 14 12 all
right
I got fire if I win this next one I'd be
in third
let's get d4 in there there are d5
Queen pawn opening there and I haven't
really seen this kind of setup going
straight for my knight um hmm I'm gonna
go here if I push they take and I don't
really want to bring my queen out so
early
let's do this if I move my pawn there's
this advance maybe I just drop back
first
uh yeah I'm gonna go just a single step
right here I think in an earlier game I
went all the way back and reply to
something in I think at least in that
game I was I thought maybe it would have
been better to defend h5 hmm it's a very
early Queen move she really going to
grab this pawn huh I don't want to move
him
yeah I guess I'll just defend nothing's
really going on just yet it's funny six
Bishop e7 castles let me try to get this
one game I don't think there's gonna be
a second game in second game that would
register for this tournament so seven
minutes forty seconds left
hmm two ten for my opponent
what are they thinking of they could
always take a knight at any moment oh
really okay well let's start with this
they have some gaps around their king
two squares Bishop e7 yeah I want to
maintain that pond and if this I think I
just won't even react to the threat on
my knight
I wouldn't mind having an extra pawn
around to help defend my king so on e5
maybe I just don't react at all three
capture at the night I could be looking
at no these light squares oh that's
actually a pretty serious move mmm I may
want to play Bishop h7 they might think
about Knight drops here let's get that
in I'll take him out yeah
secured my king position number-one
priority especially in crazy house so I
don't want him to be disrupted this
leaves a one of these interior square z6
d6 if I have to take like that it's
quite vulnerable you could see future
Knight drops like well actually they
still have a knight to drop so they were
threatening to take and then do
something like Knight f4 pointing at
both holes actually because this is the
only pawn I have around to secure both a
six and g6 now that I've moved h6 g6 is
weakened so that's what they were
threatening and I drop on f4 and
starting to chip away at these light
squares so they have another pawn I
think I need to still recapture so let's
do that they have a pawn that could drop
but to have these squares covered they
could take a bishop but he's replaced
right away Knight drops one of these two
maybe at that point I just Castle right
there just giving a chit they're really
gonna go pawn hunting is that what they
have lined up I guess
that's a that would be very bold they
did something like that I think now I
just Castle yeah let's get a castle
oh they're lining up something tricky
Wow
I'm gonna take my bishop and drop upon
here
they had that okay so maybe I should
take some action against their king this
is my opportunity to do it who cares if
they go in for that it's time to
initiate some action against their king
even though they still have this idea
present to take the bishop and then do
this a drop on c7 now that they've
provoked c6
pawn drops here I have to be on the
lookout for I'm definitely taking him
and getting another pawn back here right
away
350 now they move really quick I didn't
see though let's actually go here this
defends against this idea of a drop on
c7 and I have a couple nights I could
potentially take looking at taking upon
here and dropping on beasts b2 there
under 10 seconds
tonight how about we go here threatening
upon I may just want to go straight in
and capture it
yeah threatening to take a ruck drop
upon drop a rook here for me no let's
see where the king goes okay now we got
may in the corner back to tournament
okay we have 16 to 38 tough to get
another game in but I think I still look
up aired out 47 players in this 129 22
18 16 is where I'm at with fire so if I
somehow get this next game in for the
tournament playing against the number 2
guy I would get in 3rd if I could get
this win in but it's unlikely let's see
if we could win it win this next game 4
nights huh alright I'll take and take
again and then I guess immediately hit
the Queen seen this idea before our
night on that III square he's actually
quite a good defensive piece I must say
in that he secured his g2 some this is
the guy think that be Ferrari
is our second time playing that in this
tournament but just overall I have
another move against their queen um I
would really like to get d4 in ah let's
do this I'm a little bit fearful of a
drop on this square but I'm looking at
some captures here maybe maybe this was
a poor decision they have a knight as
well they could be dropping you know
this probably wasn't a good idea I think
I'm in trouble
mm-hmm okay well you know what I'm gonna
do I'm just gonna console hmm all right
they have two knights I'm gonna open up
this for my rook I'm threatening already
this and then this move I want to lure
their king forward yeah look at how
quick this tournament clock went under
10 seconds in the tournament clock okay
so they're defending that square noted
well let's go here
hmm can I do anything good with my pawns
no I need to defend my bishop I think no
I'm gonna hang on to him though
yeah it's worthwhile I mean I'm pointing
directly at a square right next to their
King I shouldn't be so welcome to giving
up on that pressure he's not a round of
Han drop here would be excellent I could
just
that move I have two ponds they have a
night I like that the night they placed
was is a bit Oh away from my own King
where could they put a night around okay
they're going for that hmm okay hmm
huh well training to take and if I take
swears it sooner to get my rook should I
even care about that let's start with
this yeah um that wasn't a good idea
no I just have to run with it
yikes and then they're gonna win upon
that's all right though this is crazy
house do whatever I don't know
let's go here for starters strike at the
Queen I'm also doing this because I
watch over these squares d3 is quite
sensitive thirty-two seconds one pawn in
my pocket let's see where she goes and
there all right let's throw something at
him yeah that's all you have to do huh
alright let's mix it up some it's gonna
take more material huh hmm I guess they
could why not they're under a minute
Knight takes pawn Queen here they could
do a drop on e4 that's very weakening
now hmm all right let's let's try to
work on these light squares I think that
the a move like this it's very weakening
in regular chess but crazy house that
much more okay
now their King is at least out and about
and I'm doing stuff with check I want a
queen Knight right here
well let's start with that or even a
rook here upon here if their bishop who
goes elsewhere oh really
I only had one second I didn't mean to
take it take like that should've taken
with the pawn prepared to run I'm gonna
be running but I have a knight I could
drop here hmm interesting that they
allow that although they have a knight
move here whoops they didn't see it I
got to clean i got mate oh I don't want
that they could have just taken my queen
or a knight check here uh they should
have beat me I don't know okay that's
the final not too many games in there
just five Ferrari does it again 34
Ferrari 22 18 16 and 16 that's where I
ended up okay 47 of you and that one
let's see who else played in this one
page two three four five already to the
forty-seven of you that took part in
this good games oh man
you